Greetings everybody and welcome to Rollback
our brand new YouTube only format
where we share the best evergreen conversations
from our pre-video catalog with all of you.
Today, we bring you episode number 243 from August of 2016,
where I had the great honor of sitting down
with one of the legendary basketball coaches of all time,
George Raveling.
Affectionately known as just Coach, George is many things.
He's Nike's director of international basketball,
he was the first African American assistant coach
of Villanova, the first African American assistant coach
at University of Maryland,
and seven year spent as head coach at USC
where he became quite active and outspoken
on social issues at the intersection of race, education,
and athletics.
George retired from coaching in 1994,
but to this day is considered
one of the most respected and revered figures
in not just basketball but in all of sport.
He is a national treasurer,
just an absolute gem of a human being,
a man full of life experiences and incredible stories.
Not the least of which is how on August 28th, 1963,
George came to be standing alongside
Dr. Martin Luther King Jr. at the podium
on the steps of the Lincoln Memorial
during the march on Washington as Dr. King delivered
his historic, "I Have a Dream" speech.
There is so much more to this extraordinary story,
but I don't wanna spoil anything for you
so please enjoy this Rollback to a mind blowing episode
with Coach George Raveling.
So we were introduced to each other by our mutual friend,
Ryan Holiday who I'm a big fan of
I know you are as well.
Yeah, absolutely.
I tell him I'm president of his fan club.
Yeah, he's got quite a fan club
and he speaks very, very highly of you.
He was insistent that we get together
and any friend of Ryan's is a friend of mine
so it's a pleasure and an honor
to be able to spend a little time with you today.
Well, I echo the same sentiments for you,
it's an honor for me to be on your podcast.
I appreciate that.
And just to set the stage,
we're sitting in this beautiful library,
that is wall to wall books, Florida ceiling.
Have you read all of these books?
No, no.
The answer is no, but I've read--
People send you a lot of books.
Well, I buy a lot of books,
but people send them to me too.
But I'm well fortified if the bookstores go out of business,
I'll have enough books in here
to last me for the rest of my--
Yeah, I think you're good.
My lifetime.
So I'll be...
I'm well stocked and I keep buying them.
Well, you should, right?
And I think reading is a big part of your story,
we're gonna get into the background and all of that,
but I know that reading is very important to you
and you have your Reading with Rav, right?
Is that what it's called, that goes way back?
Reading with Raveling.
Yes, I started that back in the '70s.
Yeah, let's talk about that a little bit,
the importance of reading to you
and kind of your advocacy around that.
Well, I think at the time
we had not become a technological society
in the sense that we are today,
but I think early on I realized
the unique value of information.
I used to tell my players that
perhaps the two most important commodities in the world
were information and money.
If you've got money, you can buy information.
If you've got information, you can get plenty of money.
And little did I know that we'd evolve into a culture
that we presently live in
where it's so dominated by information
and so much information is readily available to us
that you can...
If a person wanted to self-educate themself,
all they have to do is get a smart phone
and use Google servers.
About anything you can imagine, if you Google it,
you'll get anywhere from 10 to 20 articles on it
and so it's...
I think that it's comforting for me to know
that I can continue to educate myself at 79
and take myself from where I am
to perhaps where I should be intellectually
and from a knowledge gathering standpoint.
Yeah
I mean, I think technology is really shifting how we learn
and how we educate ourself.
It's democratizing it in a large way
and it's gonna be interesting to see how that plays out
over the next 10 or 20 years
and the impact that that has on
the value of the college experience and college education
when you can kind of take those matters into your own hands,
irregardless of your socioeconomic situation.
And that's a great point.
It really renders the excuse that we have poor teachers
or poor schools.
It really marginalizes that (indistinct),
because if you have poor books or poor teachers
teach yourself and all you have to have is a smartphone
to be able to do it.
But to race back to the Reading with Raveling,
I started in the '70s and I felt that
a lot of the young people that I came in contact with
were not avid readers and when I ask them why they said
that it's boring.
And so I tried to be an active listener
and they didn't say they didn't like to read
they just said it was boring.
So I started to think to myself,
if I can present to them the right topics,
maybe I can get them hooked on reading.
So if a kid like music, I give him books about music.
If he like sports, I give him books about sports.
I tried to make his ascension
from where he was to where he could be reading wise,
easy for him and not to give them the most complex books.
And the other avenue that I discovered
is particularly for younger people is to read to them.
Because there's always a child like characteristic
in all of us, even at 79,
I still enjoy hearing nice, intriguing stories.
And so I think when you read to a child,
it stimulates their mind, it takes them on a mental journey,
it heightens their curiosity.
And so what I tried to do was to give books to young people
and not reward them for reading them.
When they'd bring them back, I'd give them a little test
and I'd reward them for reading.
And over the years, I began to realize that I'd struck upon
something from an ethnic standpoint and that is that,
back in the days of slavery, the plantation owners
used to hide their money in the books
and put the books up on the shelves
because they never worried about the slaves stealing
the books or the money because they couldn't read.
That's so terrible
when you think about that.
And so what...
How I translated that was
that as long as someone can control your mind,
they can control your body.
And so if we don't allow people to possess our minds,
then they cannot possess our bodies
and so how do we achieve that by filling our head
with as much information, as much knowledge,
as much material as it possibly can.
And along the way either by intended
or unintended consequence is that
it stimulates your critical and analytical thinking.
It's just a byproduct of it.
At some point, if you read enough,
it's gonna cause you to think different, to act different,
and to be different.
But it requires a certain level
of self discipline and willingness.
And it reminds me of a speech that you gave
that I listened to the other day I think it's from 1977,
it was on your podcast where the basic theme of it was,
it's up to you.
(indistinct) is to be it's up to me.
And that was a talk that I did
to kids at our by basketball camp back in the '70s.
And as cliche says it sounds,
I think it's this powerful statement,
research would substantiate it.
And that is that at the end of the day,
nobody's gonna row our boat for us but ourselves.
We either...
Our lives are gonna be lived in a relatively orderly manner
and so either our hands
are gonna be on the steering wheel of our life
or someone else's hands are gonna be on the steering wheel
of our lives.
And I prefer that they...
That I govern my life and the way I think and I've been...
Actually, you're probably the first one
that I've talked to publicly about this,
but I've been working on this theory
that I'm gonna continue to work on over the year
until I get it really well defined,
but I call it environmental control.
And the theory behind this is
if you can control the environment in which you live,
then you can create the necessary environment
to live a peaceful, productive life, to be happy,
if in fact happiness is something that's important to you.
And so
the idea is to create a community
within this universal community.
And I can control the community that I live in.
I can control the people I associate with,
the books I read, my values, what I watch on television,
how I think.
We have a lot more control over our lives
than we realize that we do.
I just don't think that our thinking
is maybe as sophisticated as it could be or would be
if we decided...
If everyone decided once and for all that,
I'm gonna be the captain of my ship,
I'm gonna control my destiny,
I'm gonna create a path to success for me.
And if they started to control
the people that they choose to be around,
what they listen to, what they watch, their values.
I think it's very easy to do
and I didn't actually think about this in a whole lot
until the last four or five years
but I really have put that into play.
I'm very watchful of what I eat,
where I go, what I do,
and I try to create an environment in which
I feel that I can exist.
and feel like I'm making progress.
I'm not a person that believes in happiness.
I think to me happiness is
if you spend your whole life chasing happiness,
I think you're gonna be chasing a (indistinct)
because the bar's always gonna be moving.
And most times happiness is validated by someone else.
And so to me,
rather than go through all the anxiety of being happy,
I never...
This is the first time actually in a long time
that I even talked about happiness,
because I try to eradicate that word from my vocabulary.
The idea of happiness
has some sort of destination.
Yes.
But I would presume
that purpose and engagement,
sort of supplants the idea of happiness.
Yes.
In terms of being a contented
and directed individual.
I'd be more...
You picked a perfect word as it relates to me.
I'm more interested in being contented than I am being happy
because it...
And then I realize that these are momentary existence,
but you're always reaching and you get to a point
that you live and manifest,
something I learned at Nike when working there
and their mantra is there is no finish line,
that you're constantly asking yourself what's next.
And I remember Phil Knight saying to me one time,
the minute you think you've won, you're starting to lose.
Yeah, nothing is static.
Yes.
And in between the lines
what I'm hearing you speak to
is this idea of self determinism, right?
Yes.
The idea that
you can control your environment,
the adage that you're the average of the five people
you spend the most time with and the extent to which
we can control some of these factors.
And that is an idea that I believe in wholeheartedly,
but it also butts up against this kind of victim narrative
that seems to populate the news
and our culture at the moment.
The idea that everybody is a victim
and there's a lot of finger pointing
and blaming other people for the circumstances of our lives.
And on some level you're a rebuttal to that I would say.
Is that it?
Well, as it relates to me
in the minute you start to try to reach out
into these other communities and connect with them
even if it's by way of conversation or just mentally,
I think that you now run the risk
that they're gonna try to validate who you are,
what you say, or what you do.
And I'm really...
I think I'm perfectly capable of validating myself.
I don't have to live by someone else's norms
or standards for a validation.
I used to say in a talk that I did that,
the hardest battle that person
has to fight in their lifetime is to live in a world
where every single day someone's trying
to make you be someone you don't wanna be.
I think I know who I wanna be,
I don't need someone to try to make me be
who they want me to be or to live by their values.
In that I respect their values,
I respect their way of life,
and I hope that they would do the same for me.
Well, let's track it back,
the superhero origin story so to speak.
You lived through some very interesting times,
some pivotal times in our history
and you've played a significant role not just in sport
but in the culture at large through your involvement
in the civil rights movement, et cetera.
But where does it all begin?
I know it begins in Washington, DC
and had sort of an interesting family situation
when you were a kid.
It actually...
As I look quickly, try to reflect on it
and you probably touched upon
a real important item in my life
and that was the Washington, DC.
I was born in Washington, DC,
then you fast forward to the march on Washington,
which is in Washington, DC.
But I grew up in Washington, DC during the depression
when things were rationed, sugar was rationed,
flour and so forth.
And so when I was nine years old, my dad died
and when I was 13 my mom had a nervous breakdown
and she was institutionalized at St. Elizabeths Hospital
in Washington, DC for most of the rest of her life.
And so now what happens is, by and large, I'm an orphan.
And so what do you do with George?
And so my grandmother was really
the matriarch of our family.
I always envisioned her like the Pope.
She was infallible, whatever she said went.
And so my grandma worked for this white family
in Georgetown, and she had mentioned to them
about the circumstances and so the lady of the house said,
well, I think that her daughter's name was Rachel.
She said, well, Rachel works for the Catholic charities
she might be able to help you.
And lo and behold, she did.
She was able to get me in a Catholic boarding school
in upstate Pennsylvania, in a place called
Hoover Heights, Pennsylvania.
Geographically, it falls between Scranton
and Piston, Pennsylvania
up in the Northeastern part of the state.
And so I finished the rest of my education there.
I finished upgrade school, what we would call junior high
and then I went to high school.
And growing up without a father and a mother
and sort of being raised by your grandmother
and bouncing around a little bit,
I would imagine that's where the seeds of self determinism
probably were planted originally, right?
This idea that you're gonna have to be responsible
for yourself and having to shoulder that mantle
at a very young age.
Yeah, I didn't have the luxury
that comes with a family and a mom and dad in the sense
that I didn't have someone there
that was scripting out my day every...
Well I did, but it was a lot different because
when you're in a family,
there might only be four or five of you
but at the school where I was
there were over 200 young men there
and basically we were in a very disciplined environment
in order to sort of pay your way,
you had to do chores at the school.
So the time that I was there I did everything
from clean out chicken coops, to picking eggs, baling hay,
working in the bakery,
scrubbing the chapel floors on my hands and knees,
working in the laundry.
By the time that I graduated from there, I was fully trained
to live the rest of my life
and be able to take care of myself.
Even to this day I get up every morning
and I iron my pants and my shirt before I go off to work
and I'm 79 years old.
Yeah, you make your bed
you bounce a nickel off it.
Well, it was funny when I was in the army
and a lot of people get surprised
when I tell them I was in the army
but (indistinct) mandatory draft when I was there.
And so in basic training,
I did my basic training in Fort Knox, Kentucky.
And so you had to make your bed every morning
and stand for inspection and I was absolutely...
I just assumed everybody knew how to make a bed
and guys were paying...
Guys were willing to pay me 50 cents
to make their bed in the morning and that and so it...
But all those little fundamental lessons
that I learned in school they all came back
to help me along the way.
I mean, I even learned how to drive a tractor
over the course of the time there.
So what I did is I had a broad landscape
of learning opportunities outside the classroom.
It was one thing to be able to get tremendous
formal education in the classroom
but when you can couple that with life lessons
outside of the classroom,
that's a unique opportunity to grow and learn.
And that's a theme that I think
kind of over arches your coaching career, right?
The idea that these aren't just athletes,
it's not just about what happens at practice
or during the game,
but it's about shaping the hearts and the lines
of these young men.
Well, for me, what I concluded later in life
is that for me, athletics were the vehicle
that transported me along in life
and dropped me off at the right bus stops along the way
and I'd stop for a while and learn and get back on.
Athletics would take me a little further
I would've never been able to go to college
if it wasn't for basketball.
And I tell you an interesting story.
When I was a senior in high school,
I was a second leading scorer in the state of Pennsylvania
and so school started recruiting me.
So one time we were playing this team
St. Rose of Carbondale, Pennsylvania
and when I came out after the game,
a gentleman came up to me and he introduced himself.
He says, "Hi, my name's Jack Ramsey.
"I'm the coach at St. Joe's College
"and we were very interested in you."
And so I just listened.
I was always taught when grownups talk
you keep your mouth shut and you listen.
And so he said...
And he went on and told me a little bit about St. Joe's
and where it was located in Philadelphia and so forth.
And then he said, "We're gonna offer you a scholarship."
And so he said, "We'll send something to you in writing."
And I thanked him in that
and so when we got on the school bus to go back,
my coach said to me, he said,
"Who was that gentleman you were talking to?"
And I told him what had happened and I said to him, I said,
"Coach, let me ask you a question, what's a scholarship?"
I didn't even know what a scholarship was.
Oh man.
And it was such so foreign to me
and to my family that when later,
when it was just about time to graduate,
my grandma didn't...
For some reason I hadn't told her that
about the scholarship and so she was asking me,
well, what are you gonna do?
So I say, "Well, I'm gonna go to college."
And she said, "Well, how are you gonna go to college?
"Who's gonna pay for it?"
And so I said, "Oh, I'm getting a scholarship."
And so she didn't know what the scholarship was
so I explain to her and so it seemed like for two minutes
but it was probably only 10 seconds,
but she didn't say anything.
So I said, "Well, grandma, you look like you're puzzled."
And she said, "Well, I am."
And I said, "Why?"
She said, "Well, 'cause I thought
"I raised you better than that."
And I said, "Well, you did...
"I think you've done a great job in raising me."
And she says, "But I'm disappointed in myself
"because I can't believe that you're naive enough to think
"that some white people are gonna pay for you
"to go to college just so you can play basketball.
"It makes no sense, (indistinct) they're tricking you."
She says, "It doesn't work."
And you know, now it's during the hike of segregation
and that she couldn't comprehend
that white, black, blue that anybody's gonna
pay for your education to play basketball.
Yeah, times have changed.
But what was the kind of landscape
of African American athletes when you were...
First of all, when you were in boarding school, I mean,
you must have been one of the few African American students
in your school to begin with, right?
And then what about--
With about probably about 5%
of the student body were at that time
they called us either colored or negros.
And so there were about
probably I'd say maybe 5% of the student body
were what we would call today, African Americans
and that and obviously we all participate in sports.
One thing about the sports from an unusual perspective was
it didn't take us long to figure out
you wanted to participate in sports
because you got to go off for campus
and you got certain privileges.
And so maybe instead of having
to go and work in the bakery in the afternoon,
I got to go to basketball practice or I got...
So I played every sport.
I played baseball, basketball, football, and boxing.
You were at Golden Gloves in boxing, right?
Yeah, we had a...
They had a golden glove boxing team and so I went out for it
and whatever sport was gonna
get me some special privileges and get me off campus
I was for it.
But basketball was the thing.
Yes.
And then I didn't actually start playing
organized basketball until I was a freshman in high school.
And I found out later my godfather was a priest
and I found out later
probably when I was going in my senior year,
that my godfather had made a deal with the coach
that regardless of how poor I played that first year
that he wouldn't cut me from the team,
he'd keep me on the team.
And so each year I got a little better and better
but a lot of it was because I put a lot of time
in trying to master the skills.
And once again, there was a little bit of a strategy there
because if I went to the...
The nuns did all the teaching at the school
and so if I went to my homeroom teacher and I said,
Sister Dolores, I have to be...
I have to practice from 2:00 to five o'clock
well, then she would give permission to go over to the gym.
And even in the off season,
I would go in the gym every day
and work on my fundamentals and that we only had one coach.
Our coach had played for the Redskins,
but he coached every sport.
He coached basketball, baseball, football, and boxing.
And that discipline
to kinda go the extra mile
and practice in off hours.
At the time, your perception was not,
this is my ticket out or my ticket to a new life.
What was the drive?
Just a personal sense of wanting to be
as good as you could be.
Yes.
I actually, at no time in my life, did I ever say,
well, when I grow up, I wanna go to college.
And never once in our household, that when I was growing up
did anyone ever say, George, when you go grow up,
we want you to go to college.
I was unheard of.
No one in our family had ever gone
so why did they think I was gonna go?
And so, as I moved along, I began to realize that
participating in athletic brought some residual value
for you and so I utilized it to help myself grow and learn
and get exposure because I get off campus
and I get a chance to see how the rest of the world lived
because television was in its very formative stages then.
And so today, a young person can...
He has a much broader perspective of the world
than I ever had in those days.
But somewhere there was the hand of God, I guess,
just pushing me along
and being in the right place at the right time helped me.
But I don't know if I would've ever made it
other than the discipline of the nuns
and the time that they invested in me and motivated me.
And my homeroom teacher, my senior year,
her name was Sister Emmanuel
and we went through through the entire year
and she would never, ever say anything positive to me.
And then when she found out--
She's just being a good nun.
Yeah.
And when she found out I was gonna get a scholarship,
then I had...
It started to change because then they'd made me stay
every day after school and I'd have to go through
two hours of Latin and they were preparing me for the test
and teach me word derivatives and...
For example, if it's a multiple choice,
the first thing you do is go through
and eliminate the answers they can't possibly be,
so you narrow that.
So I went through all those
fundamental concepts of education.
And so when I graduated I said to her, I said,
"Sister Emmanuel," I said, "Do you realize
"in the entire year
"you've never said anything positive to me."
And she looked at me and smiled, and she said,
"Mr. Raving, do you think maybe
"there was a method to my madness?"
Yeah, it seemed to work, right?
Yeah, yes.
'Cause I was always trying to do something extra
just so she'd say I did a good job and she never would.
Well, you thrive under this
Catholic education umbrella
and then you take that not to St. Joe's but to--
Villanova.
Villanova
continuing in the Catholic tradition, right?
And you become quite a standout basketball player there.
I think what 835 rebounds or something like that
during your career
successful by any stretch of the imagination.
But even then it wasn't about,
I'm gonna become a professional basketball player.
Professional basketball looked very different back then.
Well, there weren't as many teams
and so my junior and senior year we were ranked,
nationally ranked.
And so when the...
They had six rounds of the NBA draft at that time
and I got drafted in the second round
by the Philadelphia Warriors,
which is now the Golden State Warriors.
And so the owner was a guy named Eddie Gottlieb
and I went down and I met with him
and we talked and they had a stacked line up.
They had Paul Arizin and Woody Sauldsberry
and Wilt Chamberlain and Guy Rodgers and (indistinct)
those type of players, most of whom...
Well, all went on to be in the Hall of Fame.
And so it wasn't that they needed me, but he did say that,
that I would be challenged to make the lineup, and he said,
this will show you the difference in compensation.
He said, we'd be willing to sign you for 7,500.
And you were already working at Sunoco.
So that time you were making more money in a corporate job
than you were to make--
In Sunoco
I was in a management training program
and they were paying me...
They were paying me more than that
in the management training program.
And it wasn't something that
I could ever see myself making a career out of it.
And so...
And as I said, very...
I don't know one young man my age whoever said to me
man, if I can just make the NBA, I'd be really happy.
No, that wasn't a destination point for blacks in those days
to play in the NBA.
And what...
I had an older cousin who went to Dartmouth
and then on to Georgetown Law School
and subsequently became a federal judge.
And he was kinda my role model
before I knew what a role model was
and so I always wanted to be like him.
And so he wore khaki pants all the time
so I wore khaki pants.
So whatever he did, I did.
So my idea was, okay, when I graduate,
I'll go to law school and that was gonna...
That was my pursuit.
But what's even more interesting when I look back on it
before I got to be a senior
and the scholarship came into play,
I can distinctly remember our school set up on a bluff
and down at the bottom was a highway
and the Greyhound bus came by there and so
that was how I'd get on the Greyhound bus
and take that long journey
from Pennsylvania on the Greyhound bus
till I got to Washington, DC.
And so I remember sitting up there
waiting for the bus to come
and I was thinking to myself,
boy, if I can just become a pilot in the air force,
I'll have it made.
And that was the extent of my dreams then
was to go into the air force and try to become a pilot.
I had no idea that I was ever gonna go to college.
But fate has a different path for you.
Yes.
And nonetheless,
you get pulled back into basketball
first as an assistant coach at Villanova
while you were still working your job, right?
Yes.
Your story is like...
It was like (indistinct).
(indistinct)...
I might have been the original part-time assistant, but--
And were you the first?
This starts like this wave of you being
the first of in many situations.
So you were the first African American assistant coach
in the ACC, yes?
Yeah, I was...
Actually I was the first a black assistant coach
at a predominantly white, white college,
but we didn't have all the conferences.
There was no Big Eastern there was an ACC,
but there was no...
There weren't a perforation of conferences like.
So was Villanova part of the ACC then or?
At that time Villanova was basically
in a make believe conference.
And I say that because
it didn't have a real conference structure to it,
but it was called the Big Five and the Big Five was,
La Salle, St. Joe's, Temple, Penn, and Villanova.
And so that was if those schools in Philadelphia
competed against each other and whoever had the best record,
they were the champion of the Big Five.
But basically in those days the Catholic schools
were independent, what we call independent today.
But most Catholic schools particularly
on the Eastern seaboard,
all had outstanding basketball teams.
Whatever school you name from Canisius to Villanova
to St. Joe's to Georgetown to Loyola,
they all had great basketball teams.
So you must have been how old at this time,
like 25 or something?
Yeah, I graduated...
I went to Villanova '50, '60, '60
and I was 20 when I graduated from Villanova.
So I was...
You're right,
I'd be right around 25.
Right, so that's probably like around 1962--
Yes.
Or something like that.
So this is all happening set against the backdrop of
a pretty tumultuous time in our history
with the civil rights movement
and what was going on down in Selma
with Dr. King, et cetera.
And you start to get interested in this movement
by a way of a friend and a family friend,
who kind of initiate you into these conversations
about sort of race in America,
which then leads you to show up on the mall in 1963,
to hear Dr. King.
So walk us through this extraordinary experience
that you have.
Well, this is one of those situations--
I know you've told this story
a million times
but I'm gonna make you do it.
That I characterized earlier when I said that
being in the right place at the right time.
On a Wednesday night, my best friend,
he lived in Claymont, Delaware
and Claymont Delaware is right on the border
of Pennsylvania and from (indistinct) over to Claymont
is maybe an hour and some change.
And so I was down at their house for dinner
and my friend's name was Warren Wilson
and his dad was a very prominent black, Dennison Wilmington.
And so we were having dinner and in those days,
families always gathered for the evening meal
and there was always a conversation.
And so Dr. Wilson asked us if we were gonna go
to the March on Washington that weekend, and we said, "No."
And he asked us, "Why not?"
He said, "This is gonna be a historic moment.
"You guys should be there."
And so we gave him one of those adolescent excuses
we didn't have any money or way to get there.
So he said, "Well, I can fix that."
So he let us use the car and he gave us money
to go down there.
So that Friday we hopped in the car
and we drove down to DC and we got a motel room on...
At that time there was...
Route 1 was the only (indistinct) in and out of DC
going north and south.
And so we found a hotel room or motel room
on New York Avenue and we decided that
we'd drive down that evening, Friday evening
and just get our bearings and see what was going on.
And while we were down there,
we ran into this guy and he said,
"Hey, are you coming tomorrow?"
And we said, "Yes."
And he said,
"Well, would you guys be interested in volunteering?"
And we said, "For what?"
He said, "Oh, we're gonna have twice as many people
"as we thought we were gonna have.
"And so we're gonna have to have a double security
"so we're looking for volunteers.
"Would you guys wanna volunteer?"
And we said, "Yes."
So he said, "Be down here tomorrow morning at 9:00."
And we woke up early and got down there
and we got down there about 8:00, maybe 8:15,
and we found them and he said, "Wow, you guys--"
Like right on the--
On the mall.
Yeah, in the mall...
Yeah, the mall there where the reflecting pool in that is.
And so he said, "You guys are here early."
He said, "Well, we're gonna double the security up
"at the speakers podium 'cause they had people speaking."
John Lewis who's now in Congress
was one of the early speakers that day.
So it started from 9:00 in the morning
and King was the last speaker late in the evening
around 5:00.
All day people speaking.
Yes, there's one speaker--
And everyone had like six minutes, right?
No, five minutes.
Five minutes.
Everybody was limited to five minutes and they...
You had to give them
an advanced copy of your speech for approval
and they made John Lewis change his about 10 times.
Baldwin, James Baldwin refused to change his
and so they wouldn't let Baldwin speak.
And so even King, the original speech was five minutes.
And so what happened was there was this security structure
and particularly for King as soon as he was done speaking,
we were to surround and golf him
and take him out the back way and we had an exit plan
if there was some kind of over demonstration or violence.
Were you up on the...
By the podium the whole day or just for Dr. King?
(indistinct) pictures.
No, I was up there the whole day
and we got a break every now and then
to go grab a...
There was a place in the back
where you could go and get a sandwich and something
called (indistinct)
but basically I was on duty the entire time.
And so throughout the course of the day,
people were still coming in
and by the time King got up to speak,
the place was as far as you could see was human humanity.
People...
In fact, when we left that evening around 7:30
to head back up to Delaware,
the people were still trying to get into DC
and it was over and it was bumper to bumper
until we got Baltimore.
People still--
Right there those...
There's famous footage and images
of just a sea of people all the way down
the reflecting board.
So King got up to speak
and he was going through his prepared text
and he gets to a point when I would suggest
he's probably three quarters of the way through
the prepared text
and you hear a female voice say,
"Tell them about the dream, Martin.
"Tell them about the dream."
Was seated behind King were Mahalia Jackson
who most people would suggest
is the greatest gospel singer of all time.
And Marion Anderson she had sang the national anthem.
And so it was Mahalia Jackson who had encouraged Martin
to tell about the dream.
And so what was the dream?
The dream part
King had used in the speech in Detroit earlier that week
and he had used it in Selma
and Mahalia Jackson was on both of those programs
so she was familiar with it and obviously inspired by it.
And so at this point, King was the last speaker
and some people would say that he was the keynote speaker
but that wasn't true.
They put King last
because they know he would hold the crowd.
And so at that point, he deviates from the speech
and ad libs in the "I Have A Dream" portion.
And as a result was he was the only speaker
who went past the five minute mark.
Was there a moment
when you standing next to him knew?
Like, was it palpable in the moment like,
okay, he's not referring to his notes and--
No, because I didn't have the notes.
I didn't have the notes at that point.
But like sort of kicking into a high gear--
No, I think King was such
a was a highly skilled author that he...
You were mesmerized, your thought process certainly was.
And particularly for me, I didn't have the knowledge
or the analytical skills to try to dissect his speech
in that I was just like everybody else
I was just like being in church on Sunday, you know?
And so once King finished,
the place went berserk.
And so now we started to close in
and as you can see by the picture,
just as he begins to finish the speech
and is moving away from the podium, he's folding it.
And we actually have on a video King folding the speech
and I said to him, "Dr. King, can I have that speech?"
And he handed it to me.
You actually have that on video?
Yeah, and CBS found it in the archives.
Is it online anywhere, I'd love to see that.
Oh yeah, it's on my website.
Oh, it is, okay.
If you look at the James...
There's about five different networks
have done documentaries, but the one with CBS,
with James Brown, you can see it.
Right, I'll check that out.
And so--
So you just spontaneously
have this idea that--
Yeah, I don't know why
I'd love to some great story
that I had this whole thing premeditated, but I didn't.
And so just as he handed it to me,
the rabbi who was gonna say in the benediction said to him,
"Dr. King, that's the greatest speech I've ever heard.
"I loved your speech."
And so his tension is switched from me
and his focus to the rabbi and that was the end of it.
And I just stuck it in my pocket and then when it was over,
we ushered him out.
So now the leadership group, A. Philip Randolph
and Martin Luther King and the Bayard Rustin
and those people who led to March,
they all go to the White House to meet the president.
And when they walk into the Oval Office,
President Kennedy says, "Dr. King," he says,
"I loved your 'I Have a Dream Speech.'"
The speech has no title, but the media picked up on it
and called it the "I Have a Dream Speech" which was unusual
because that really was never--
It wasn't even in the text.
No, it wasn't even in the text.
And so that became the way that it was given its name
by the media.
But it was a just a magnificent time.
King had spent a lot of time the night before
writing and rewriting the speech.
And he actually grappled with trying to figure out
how to get the I have a dream portion in,
but it wasn't gonna meet the timeline
and so he ultimately left it out.
But they let him go on for like...
Was like 16 minutes,
Yeah.
Well, once he got up there at that point--
There was no stopper.
There was no stopping him
and the crowd would've gone berserk if they tried to
because they had told people that,
hey, if you go over we're just gonna cut the mic.
But he was the last one up anyway, right?
Yes.
And I mean...
What did someone say?
Don't mess with history.
Yeah.
Well, speaking of history, so this speech goes down
as arguably one of the greatest speeches
in American history, if not the history of humanity
up there with J. Kennedy's inauguration speech--
Churchill and the Gettysburg address.
In the moment was there a sense
of that level of momentousness?
I don't think so because I don't know
that black people were ever allowed
to think in such grand terms.
Who would've ever thought
that there would be a moment in history
when there was an evaluation of speeches
that moved the nation and moved the nation's conscious
and one of them would be by a black person.
We have to also be mindful that it took 50 years.
Malcolm X said one time that,
history is best situated to reward all man's deeds.
And so my interpretation in that
is history is best situated
to place things in their historic context.
So it took 50 years for that speech
to really be evaluated accurately
and placed in the historic context
as it related to other speeches
that had a meaningful effect on our social system
and our values.
And meanwhile, you have the actual text,
you stick it in a book that was...
Yeah, I had the actual speech.
Harry Truman's biography that--
It's right...
The book is right behind you in the bookcase, yeah.
So what happened my senior year in college,
I played an East West All Star game in Kansas City
and they took us out to Independence Missouri
to meet President Truman.
And when we were out there,
when he was done visiting with us, he had a (indistinct)
above three tables with books stacked high on him.
And he had written his two volume set of on his presidency.
And so he gave each of us a set
and mine says to George Raveling...
It's got the date 1960 and to George Raveling
from Harry S. Truman and both of them were signed like that.
So I put the speech inside of it
because I knew one, I'd remember
two, that I would never throw those books away
because how many people can say
that they have a personally autographed book
by the president of the United States.
And so it's--
But you actually
don't end up really remembering it, right?
It sort of escapes your memory--
No.
So for 25 years...
For 25 years, I never thought about it
and my wife didn't even...
No one knew I had it.
And I never talked about it because at that point
it hadn't taken on its historic significance.
Even after the assassination?
No.
When I...
How it became public was when I went from
Washington state as head basketball coach to Iowa.
When I got to Iowa,
obviously the first black head coach there.
And so at that time, most of the major newspapers
had a Sunday magazine section that came with it
and the New York Times is one of the few papers
that still have their own.
And so the the Cedar Rapids Gazette
sent a reporter down to do this story on me
and so as going through the questions,
I call it a throwaway question he just said to me,
"Coach, were you ever involved in a civil rights movement?"
And I said, "Kinda," and he said, "What do you mean kinda?"
And I explained to him what happened.
And he said, "Oh my God, you have the speech.
"Where is it?"
And I said, "It's down in the basement in some boxes,"
'cause I'd only been there about two or three weeks
and I hadn't unpacked yet.
And so we go down in the basement and we find it
and I thought the guy was gonna have a heart attack.
He was hyperventilating and then he called the sports editor
and said, "Oh my God, you can't believe what happened."
And he asked, was it okay to send a photographer down,
to take a picture of it.
And so that was the first time that anyone knew
that I had the speech.
But even then it didn't cause a gigantic uproar.
I used to keep it on the wall in my office
but then once it became more...
The government officially anointed
a day for Martin Luther King Day, now people,
the story was getting around.
ESPN had it on, Digger Phelps would always bring it up
on a program that Coach Raveling has the original speech.
And so more and more people started to understand
that I had it.
And my wife got a little nervous because she felt
you travel a lot--
You could get the house broken into.
Yeah, somebody had break into the house
so she said, we gotta move it out and put it in the bank.
Or take it out of the book.
Yeah.
And so we moved it out of the house because...
And she's always said back in those days,
make sure you keep saying publicly it's not in the house
because I don't want somebody breaking into our house
and trying to steal.
But it would be...
If it were still in the house now
there would be a more likelihood that
someone would probably try to into break to the house now
because we live in such an unstable environment.
But in those days,
I don't know that there was any real threat to us
and people weren't really...
I mean, such a large city like Los Angeles,
people weren't even sure where I lived.
So over the years,
I'm sure there's been suitors,
people trying to buy this from you,
estimates run anywhere from a couple million bucks
all the way up to like $25 million.
You've repeatedly refused to sell it.
But I would...
And I can understand the reasons behind that
and I wanna dig into that a little bit more deeply,
but it must have occurred to you,
why not share it with the Smithsonian, put it on loan
so everybody can enjoy it.
I agree with you
and that's exactly what we're gonna do.
I had been consistently saying that
I was gonna leave it to my son when I die
and that still my intention.
But even--
So long as he doesn't sell it.
Yes, so long as he doesn't sell it.
And so about two years ago,
the gentleman who was the producer of the CBS documentary
on me having this speech is a young man named Alvin Patrick.
And he had encouraged me to go down
and meet with the people at the New African American Museum,
which is part of the Smithsonian.
And I went down and I met with them
and they were very gracious and it is our intention
to get...
I think it just opened a few weeks ago.
And so it's our--
Oh, it's that beautiful new...
They just built it, right?
Yes.
I was just in Washington last week,
I saw it.
It's magnificent looking building.
And so ultimately within the next 12 months
it'll be housed there.
Oh, that's fantastic, that's great.
So I can't help, but wonder,
you keep characterizing this as right place, right time,
but on some level it almost seems faded.
You are this sort of paradigm breaking person in sports
in that being the first African American
assistant coach at Villanova
and then going on to coach at University of Washington
and then--
Washington state.
Washington state, Iowa--
And USC.
And at each one of those sort of train stops
being the first African American coach.
Again, set against this kind of interesting time
in the evolution of civil rights
and then being the sort of
repository of this landmark speech on some level
doesn't the message seep through to you.
Like, I'm...
There's a reason behind all of this.
Like what is the responsibility that you feel
to speak to these issues
as somebody who is carrying on in the tradition of Dr. King
and somebody who has himself broken through barriers?
Well, I'd think that with each passing year,
I became much more aware of what was
the larger world around me
and I grew to understand that we lived out the cliches
of the last hired and the first fired
that we live in ghettos.
When I was growing up, I never even realized
I lived in a ghetto until I got to Villanova
and took a sociology class.
And I mean I was perfectly happy with my life
even though most of it was in a boarding school.
But as I grew older, I began to put my life
and my pursuits in a broader context and I realized that
that one of the impediments that I was gonna carry with me
for the rest of my life was my pigmentation
and people were gonna judge me differently.
But over the years, I also grew to understand that,
that the one thing that most people
respect about another person is their intellect,
whether you're black, white, whatever.
They might still have misgivings about you
but they will respect your intellect.
And so I try to compensate by being an information gatherer
a knowledge gatherer trying to learn as much as I could
so that I could effectively compete in our social system
even if I had all the hardships and the drapings
that came with segregation or discrimination.
At the end of the day, it was incumbent upon me
to figure out how can I successfully compete
in this environment?
What are the skills I need?
What are the things I need to do?
And one of those things was obviously to be able
to have a courageous voice and stand up
and speak out against injustice.
Everybody can't be Malcolm X or Martin Luther King,
or Stokie Carmichael or Huey Newton.
I think there's all of us have a role to play in life
and we have to figure out what that role is
and we have to play it.
But at the end of the day,
we have to accept the responsibility
that it's a moral obligation to speak out against
injustice and inequality.
And here we are today
and it's a more sophisticated type of discrimination.
And it's now not something that
is just discrimination against a person
because of the pigmentation of their skin.
There's discrimination against women,
there's discrimination against gays,
there's discrimination against Latinos and that.
And so it's become a societal problem in a real sense.
I remember Moynihan in his report center Moynihan,
when he did the report on black America
he suggested that the number one problem in black America
was the broken home structure
that you had this ever-growing population of black people,
black children who were being raised
in single parent households
and because of the judicial system,
the courts tended to award the child to the woman,
the mother.
And so they were growing up in a home
without male role models, without male supervision.
But what we soon began to realize
that over the coming years,
it really wasn't a black problem,
it was an American problem
because we have equal amount of white children
who grow up in single parent households too.
And so over the course of time,
this so-called social and discriminatory systems
became cancerous and they grew
and they started to spread out beyond the black communities
and to white communities and to Latin communities
and to Asian communities.
And so over the years, I've watched it,
this racial demographic journey to here.
I go from Washington, DC to Los Angeles,
I live in a city now in Los Angeles
where the ethnic breakdown is the dominant ethnic group
in Los Angeles are Latinos, Asians, blacks, whites.
And so much progress has been made.
Here we are in the twilight of
the eight years of the Obama administration,
first African American president.
Professionals for the NBA, the NFL is gotta be around 80%
African American at this point in terms of players
which is a massive shift from your days of being a player
and perhaps the early days of you coaching.
And yet we're also in a social and political climate
that seems more divided than ever.
So when you think about,
you had mentioned earlier we all have a role to play,
how do you think about and articulate
how you see your...
Like what is your role?
Like how would you define
what your role in this grand play is?
I see myself as a servant leader.
I think at this juncture in my life,
I'm kind of on the other side of the mountain now at 79.
And so I fully recognize it's no longer about me,
it's about them.
And so I have to reach out and try to positively
affect as many lives as I can.
And so my mission every day is
to be a positive difference maker
and as many lives of people as I can,
black folks and white folks.
And I try to target young people and share with them
my life lessons and hopes that my grandma used to say,
if you listen to me, I can help you avoid
some of the bumps and potholes in the road.
And so that I...
To this day, I still feel that that's my mission
to help other people avoid some of the potholes in the road
because I've lived a life that they have to live
and so I'm gonna spend all of the rest of my remaining life
trying to be a positive difference maker
in as many lives as I possibly can.
And when I look back now in my life,
I've lived a variety of lives.
I truly believe when I look back on my life
that you live your life in buckets.
Say 10 to 20, 20 to 30, 30 to 40.
But when I was 40 years old,
I was no longer the person I was when I was 30 years old
and at 79 I'm not the same person I was at 69.
What's the biggest difference?
I think one, you're in a constant,
your values change, your interest change,
your health changes, your thinking changes.
And then you get to a point where you have no choice anymore
about changing.
Technology has ushered into my life and forced me to take on
a whole new existence.
I mean, I have to learn the language of technology,
I have to learn the utilization of technology,
I have to learn the value that it creates for me.
And fortunately it came at a time in my life
with the proper use of technology,
it's allowed me to remain relevant
in a time in my life that's very important
because now I'm able to transfer from old thinking
to new thinking, from old knowledge to new knowledge.
To be successful and compete in society today,
we have to relearn things, we have to rethink things,
we have to acquire new knowledge
that's relevant in this time.
I would imagine it gets...
It must get harder as you get older.
I mean, most people who are, settling into their 70s and 80s
are kind of the catchphrase where
you're just stuck in your ways like you...
At some point, that evolution sort of stops
and you're just not gonna get the new iPhone,
it's just not gonna happen.
Or you're not gonna figure out the new TV remote.
It's like you draw a line in the sand and you're like done,
but what I'm hearing you say is you are committed to--
You're only done if you think you're done.
Well, the amazing thing
is you have this incredibly robust website.
Like when I went to your website the first time I thought,
(indistinct)...
You don't have your bio.
I didn't expect there to be very much content
and yet there's all kinds of articles there
and podcast and video interviews and the book club
and here's my monthly recommendations
for what you should be reading,
like a ton of amazing, really helpful, inspiring content.
And I thought, wow, this guy's like really
with what's going on right now
and that must take a level of attention and energy and focus
that I think most people at your age
probably just aren't that interested in.
Well, I'll back to
what I said before is that I can control my environment now.
You rarely ever see me other than with...
And my wife is not the same age as I
but you will rarely ever see me hang around with
or associate with people that are my own age.
I'll...
'Cause you and Ryan Holiday are hanging out.
No.
I hang around with younger people
because they help me think young,
they teach me how to use technology,
I can listen to them and they're all...
The young people are my mentors.
They're the ones that are...
They're my teachers, they're my professors right now
and they stimulate me
because if I hang around with people of my own age,
the talk is always gonna be about the past and the now,
young people are talking about
they're looking into the future,
they're defining what the future is.
And so I find it stimulating to be around them
and to listen and hang onto their coattail
because if I hang on
they're gonna drag me into the future with them
and that's where I wanna be.
My biggest challenge is,
I'm an African American ex basketball coach, 69 years old,
how do I stay relevant in this contemporary time?
I don't...
I don't wanna be put in a position
where I'm living my life in reverse.
I wanna live my life going forward.
And so what I've done is I boiled it down to this equation
and this question...
And the question I ask myself on a consistent basis is this,
what is it that I don't know but I need to know
to remain relative and competitive and growing
and prospering in today's society.
And then I constantly search on what I don't know,
but what I need to know and the great part about it is,
is all I gotta do is go on my iPhone, hit Google,
and I can educate myself.
I told my wife the other day, I said, you know what,
I'm tired of hearing night after night quoting these polls.
And with...
As if we are to accept those as being valid
'cause I have all kind of questions, okay.
Who did you poll?
I'm 79 never had been polled once in my life.
How many people did you poll?
What were the questions that you asked?
What was their political affiliation?
And I got a lot of things.
So I told my wife, I said, you know what,
I'm gonna educate myself so that I can critically analyze
and think about this thing about polls
and I'm gonna start questioning all these assumptions
about polls.
So I Google and I...
I went on Google and I asked for books on political polls
and about 20 of them came up
and so I picked out five of them and I ordered them
and I'm gonna read it.
In 60 days from now,
I am gonna be challenging people...
No, I'm gonna be challenging--
Come November.
Yeah, I'm gonna challenge people's--
I like it.
And I'm gonna challenge the networks
when they give us this.
I mean, Quinnipiac or New York Times or Wall Street poll.
What makes their opinion any more valid
than your opinion or my opinion?
Yeah, there's a lot of science
that goes into crafting those questions
to drive a certain result.
Well, I could talk to you about this stuff
for like six hours,
but I know we're on a little bit of a leash here.
Well, we gotta do it again.
Well, I'm just sitting here thinking
while you're answering I'm like, there's no way
I'm gonna get to all this stuff I wanna talk to you about.
So you're gonna definitely have to come back
and we can fill in the gaps.
But maybe we can shift gears a little bit here
and just talk about coaching in general.
This has been your career,
you're one of the great legendary coaches of all time.
So I'm interested in your thoughts about,
how you perceive the importance of coaching
and what are the distinguishing features of a great coach?
What makes a great coach great.
Well, I'll try to answer
the last part of it first.
I think what makes a great coach great
is his ability or her ability
to consistently get the athlete
to operate at peak efficiency.
To get the absolute best out of each individual
and to motivate them to greater heights.
To me, coaching is one of the greatest honors
you can ever have in your lifetime.
And so why do I feel that way?
Because a parent
is gonna take their most valuable possession, their child,
and they're gonna put them in your hands
and they're gonna allow you to influence them.
And so you have a huge responsibility.
I recruited a young man named Mark Boyd
from Stone Mountain in Georgia when I was at USC.
And after his mom signed the letter of intent
and she was walking me to the door,
she looked at me and she said,
"Coach Raveling, I don't want no foolishness outta you now."
And I knew what she meant.
Hey, I've raised this young man with a certain value system
and I expect you to expand on that,
I expect you to respect that.
And so to me, I feel sincerely
and this was a motivating factor with me.
If all a young man learned
during the four years he was with me
because in those days you didn't have one and done.
If all I taught him was how to shoot jump shots and rebound
and play defense and win basketball games,
hell could have gone anywhere and got that.
I want the four years with me to be a unique experience.
I want the things that he learned
to spill over from the basketball court into everyday life.
You have a responsibility as a coach to tell him
how the game athletics prepares him for the game of life
'cause at the end of the day,
the most important game to win is the game of life.
And so--
And what's your core philosophy
at the bottom of that?
Like what--
Well, I think it's a system that...
It's a secondary system of education.
You'd learn so much about life lessons
from participation in athletic.
You learn you don't win all the time,
you don't lose all the time.
You learn you have to sacrifice,
you have to be a team player,
you have to be teachable and coachable,
you have to play with whites and blacks and Hispanics.
You learn that you've gotta be a listener,
you gotta make quick decisions on the run.
There's so many things that you learn from athletics.
You learn leadership.
And so all these things are the early preparation
for your transformation from participating in sports
and you take those values with you into society.
But we have to get people to see the connection
between their participation
and its preparation for you in the future.
Very small segment of kids are gonna make it to the NBA
and probably less than 1% of the black kids in America
are ever gonna play in the NBA,
but their participation can be more important
and should more important than participating in the NBA.
That's what bothers me about this one and done.
One and done puts too much emphasis on material things
and money and not enough emphasis on education.
That's what I worry about it.
I don't deny that a young person
is physically talented enough to participate at that level,
but does he have the...
Does he have the educational fundamentals
that he's gonna need.
If you're making $100 million a year,
you can't even sit in the media
and ask an intelligent question
because you don't have the educational background.
Well, and if you don't have
a mature character, then you're more...
You're probably gonna make some bad decisions.
Absolutely.
And I used to do a talk called voices and choices
and the thesis is that the voices you listen to
are the ones that determine the choices that you make.
And so know at the end of the day
if you listen enough of the right voices,
you'll make the right choices.
If you listen enough to the wrong voices,
you're gonna make a bad choices and that.
And I think today, when you look at the compensation
for professional athletics,
education is more important today than it's ever was.
If you can couple education with a professional career
and the compensation that you have,
you can help change the world because you...
But you've got to be able
to put the physical with the mental.
See there's far too much emphasis on the physical now
and not enough emphasis on the mental.
Is that what you would characterize
as the most common mistake or misstep
that most coaches make.
Absolutely.
And it starts on the basketball court
because you hear of all the skill development today
in athletics, but it's so out of balance
because all the skill development does with the physical,
there's no one spending a whole lot of time
working with the athlete on the mental part of the game.
If you can combine the physical with the mental,
ooh, you got a heck of a thing going for you now.
One of the things that everybody says
about you is that you are this amazing recruiter.
You had an eye and an ability
to really spot talent like above and beyond.
So when you are in that capacity, what are you looking for?
Like, what is the defining characteristic
of the great athlete or the unpolished gem?
What is the difference between
somebody who in your eyes is good
or has the potential to be good
and that rare special athlete who could be fantastic?
I don't know that it's any one thing.
I would think at the end of the day
some of the things I try to look at an athlete
and not look at necessarily where he is now
or where she is now,
but where can they be 5 years or 10 years from now.
Are they coachable?
Are they teachable?
Do they have a passion for the game?
What type of skills do they have?
Have they reached their ceiling?
And one of the reasons
I think I achieved success at Washington state
was because I was never able to get to super star.
I think in recruiting
anybody can go out and watch Willie Major
or OJ Simpson play
and conclude that they're gonna be a star.
But it's that guy that's a notch...
I mean, let's take the present day flavor of the month,
Steph Curry.
I mean most of his life he's been in a constant battle
to prove people wrong.
He's too small, he's too thin, he can't guard anybody.
But he took that and used it as a motivator
to propel him where he is today.
And so now he's the MVP of the league.
But we have to remember, he couldn't get a scholarship
coming outta high...
Davidson, picked him up at the end,
Virginia Tech wouldn't even take him as a walk on
(indistinct)--
Do you think
you could have spotted him outta high school?
Do I think...
I don't know that I would've.
I might have been a little bit more intrigued of him
because of his ability to shoot the ball
because at the end of the day,
the game of basketball comes down
to putting the ball in the basket
and stopping it from getting in the basket.
And so he had a unique skill right away,
he knew how to get it in the basket.
All those other offenses and all that stuff were fine,
but you don't need the offense for Steph Curry.
Just give him the ball and he gets across half court
he picks it up, shoot, boom, goes in the basket
and it simplifies the game in the process.
I gotta let you go.
We're at our time limit and I can't believe it
because we didn't even talk about
all the things that you do at Nike.
I wanted to talk to you about the--
Well, we're gonna do it again.
The Olympics, all kinds of stuff.
I'm sitting here with all these notes
that I didn't even get to,
but this has been brilliant and amazing.
You're quite the inspiring character,
I really appreciate your time.
It's absolute pleasure to talk to you, so thanks a lot.
I wanted to kinda get like
these modern TV shows now where there's a Q&A.
Where the person that's being asked the questions,
they start interviewing the person who's doing it.
So I didn't even get a chance.
Maybe I need a new co-host.
You can come in every once in a while and chime in.
No, no.
Heck I wanna talk to you out swimming at Stanford
and go back and...
Heck I had teams with five guys
who if I combined all their SATs,
they couldn't have gotten to Stanford.
Time has changed,
I don't think I could get in there anymore now either.
But fantastic, thank you very much.
Thank you.
If you're digging on this
the best way to connect with you, you're all over the place,
but your website is coachgeorgeraveling.com.
Yes.
And on there you can find the podcast
and the videos and all kinds of articles.
Yeah, I put up five new books every month...
There's easily a...
So what are the books on the list
maybe we can leave everybody with a reading list.
Well, the book of the month is Ryan's book
on ego.
Ah, of course.
Well, everybody already knows about that one.
Yes, yeah.
Maybe what's the other book
that you tend to hand out quite a bit.
Actually, one of the books that I recommend
is an old book it's called
"What They Don't Teach You at Harvard Business School"
by Mark McCormack.
That was a book that greatly influence my life.
There's a book out now
that I think is a little bit of sleeper book.
I don't remember the author's name now,
but it's called "Practice Perfect."
I have it on a coffee table in my office.
And one of my good friends is a professor
at Wharton School in Penn
and she was the one that pointed it out to the book to me.
And what made me go by the book immediately was she said,
this is one of the best business books
I've read in a long time and she reads 100 books a year.
So the fact that she said
it was one of the best she ever read, I went out and got it.
And it's called "Practice Perfect,"
I don't recall the author's name now but--
I'll put a link to it in the show notes
for people that wanna check it out.
But as you can see from my collection here,
I really have--
You got quite a few things here.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's pretty cool.
And you're on Twitter at George Raveling,
you got a Facebook page, all that kind of stuff.
So reach out to George, tell him you enjoyed the interview
and let's do this again really soon.
Absolutely.
You let me know, we'll get on each other's calendar
and if I have to come out the Malibu,
I'll come out to Malibu.
We'll cook a meal for you.
Yep.
Great, thank you.
Peace.
Plants.
(lighthearted music)